[Music]
my job is to win Here Comes cish cavish
is going to do
itav the again Mark Cavendish is the
greatest Sprinter in the history of
cycling that was just a piece of magic
Mark Cavendish one of the most
successful sprinters of all time I'm
still doing what I love as a job but you
forget that you're doing what you love
as a job Mark has won an astonishing 34
stages of the tour to France if you put
it into the kind of context of what a
race is you learn from positives and
negatives don't you have a good look
before a bad look now that's life that's
bite racing you
know how are you feeling about the
season that lies ahead yeah good if I do
everything I can do the best that I can
do it then I'm happy there's a pressure
to winner and it's how you deal with
that that is the biggest factor between
first and second there's so many little
things about about sport which make it
just
[Music]
beautiful it's a different kind of race
this
year I'm extremely proud to introduce
you to our newest brand partner on check
out their lineup of super comfortable
sleek and durable pieces for yourself at
[Music]
on.com thanks so much for doing this man
it's a it's pleasure to meet too I'm
honored that you made the time I can't
imagine how you feel right now you were
in Japan yesterday I don't know what
time it is for you right now but you did
a criterium like Sunday right today's
Monday yeah it's so weird like leaving
Japan and then arriving here before I
left it's like being in a Sci-Fi movie
or you know I've never like skipped a
day normally always between Europe I so
yeah we'll see how long we go before I'm
like hitting the micop my head go easy
on you man we're all friends here um and
we're in this very unique auto garage uh
because you couldn't make it across town
so I'm glad we could accommodate it I
know you do I mean obviously you do a
ton of media but you haven't done a ton
of this kind of media these types of
podcasts so you know I appreciate you
being open to it that's no problem I
don't actually do that much media
anymore we have media commitments we
have to do round racing but I don't
really do even that much media anymore
really how has the Netflix documentary
being out there kind of changed how
people interfac with you like average
people who aren't Gearheads do you know
what like it it frown me because it's
been so overwhelmingly positive like
nothing's ever really happened to me
positive without something negative to
counter yeah counterbalance it you know
and it's been quite overwhelming like I
wanted to just lock myself in the garage
for two months cuz like I just said like
that you're waiting for okay can't be
something good without mhm the backlash
yeah and then uh I think mostly was like
quite laying myself be you know as a
sports person you don't I guess the best
way to describe is you play a character
don't you you know like not necessarily
too fans and that but your rals you know
especially as a sprinter you have to
there's there's a
certain I guess stereotype that goes
with that and it's a lot of Mind Games
as well as physical just to lay my real
self out there flaws and all is quite
feel a bit exposed actually you know
like not in a bad way it's not like H
terrified but I just kind of wanted to
close myself off from the world and
that's interesting I mean I think two
observations on that the first thing is
just your openness to even doing it like
I was curious if that decision was made
when you thought you were going to
retire because it's one thing to do
something like this post career to open
yourself up and to be vulnerable on that
level you know sort of like how Beckham
did recently with his with his thing but
for you to be still in the sport and
like reveal a side of you that perhaps
there's an aspect of your competitive
nature that wishes you know people
didn't know it's not surprising that you
feel that way but I also think my second
observation is that that is an extension
of all the work that you've done on your
mental health to feel okay about putting
that out there like this exploration in
vulnerability and realizing that it
doesn't need to negatively impact your
performance and in fact you know
evidence has shown that it's made you
stronger and more resilient and has
contributed to your longevity in the
sport yeah that's true we've talked
about the stuff with the film with
everything that happened in the film
it's quite organic actually like
actually when we decided to do something
it was kind of
before all that stuff happened and then
just it completely changed because CU
all that happened oh so it's been going
on for a long time that making it yeah
there's a lot more impact with it now
anyway than what would just being a sure
highlights of my career really you know
yeah I mean it's a documentary about
mental health that's what it is
especially now it's talked about a lot
more which is which is great so you
don't mind it there MH actually like the
biggest thing I say is that
from my personal view of mental health
like before I suffered I thought it was
an excuse
you know like in fact there's actual
things I see in some of my competitors
in the past that if I knew then what I
know now like I perhaps prayed on
problems that some of my competitors had
without knowing like I said I thought
just snap out of it like like what's
wrong with you like I'm not glad I I I I
suffered and suffer like I wouldn't wish
it on anybody but
at least I can understand and not just
someone that wasn't thought about it I
really thought it was an excuse yeah
just pull yourself up out of the gutter
what's your problem in your mind move
forward exactly so now I can really talk
about it with experience MH like take it
seriously like a for one was not one
that not not I wasn't
even didn't think about it I just didn't
take it seriously at all as somebody
who's who's been doing this for a very
long time I'm sure you've gotten really
good at figuring out what your
competitor's weaknesses are you're going
to exploit those physically but like how
can you exploit those mentally right
with you know how you're interacting
with these people uh does it does it
make you less inclined to do that or are
you still able to kind of deploy that no
a lot less like cliche smack talk say do
you know which was something I employed
quite a lot in the past just don't do it
now just any negative negativity is as a
whole do you know when they say like
when when you're a kid like you make
yourself better to be better don't make
people worse for you to be better like
it's that on a on a grownup level I
guess I mean you're a grown up you know
and you actually seem like you seem like
a much happier person like a more
grounded person you're approaching the
sport more from a perspective of joy and
gratitude than just being like on that
like Edge where Winning is Everything
and it's so interesting that the
documentary is called Never Enough right
like I'm sure your definition of that
has changed from you know how you might
have thought of that in earlier years
yeah after that kind of thing back and
think what I was thinking it's hard to
do that cuz it's just you you know like
when you when you have to kind of
explain who you were what it was just
you so you don't really know you just
know like with everything in life like
with a race if you put it into the kind
of context of what a race is you learn
from positives and negatives don't you
if you win even even though you've won
you might still have made mistakes or
you might have done something new and
you learn and you you you you put that
into into play the next time you go out
and more importantly when you don't win
like you learn from from what you did
wrong and try and put that into practice
next next time and Life's a lot like
that I guess and you learn the older you
get the the wiser you are of
course the best thing for for learning
moving forward is make a mistake you
know or or doing things maybe you not
you don't necessarily regret them but
maybe you think back I would have done
that different and then you have kids as
well and yeah that changes that changes
yeah exactly exactly what life is all
about and why you do things and I don't
know I don't know if it's growing up or
it's what I've been through or what but
I'm just like I used to Harbor
negativity and actually it served me
quite well sometimes because that it it
created a fire but I tell you you feel a
lot lighter if you just don't har
negativity negativity towards people or
towards something you've done or R but
it's scary to let go of that it's a very
reliable fuel source you know and it
served you well it's part of the
equation this is how I win right and the
prospect of like hey you're going to
have to let go of that if you want to
get over this hump and continue to race
and you're going to have to find a new
fuel source I would imagine that's
terrifying for anybody who's who's
acclimated to kind of that
perspective yeah just just enjoy it it's
kind
of it sounds so silly it sounds so
simple so cliche but if you can enjoy
and appreciate every pedal rev makes
everything worthwhile with what you're
doing like I get to do what I love as a
job you know and when I first turned
professional I realized that but very
quickly you know I was world champion I
won everything I did and you forget that
and I'm still doing what I love as a job
but you forget that you're doing what
you love as a job my job is to win you
know and uh that's kind of I want to win
for sure but that pressure is put from
an
outside entity you know right and right
right right so you're you're just so
literally like a month ago you just
announced that you weren't retiring and
you were coming back so how much of that
decision is about like the joy piece
like I love what I do I love riding my
bike I love the the camaraderie and
being at these races versus the project
35 got to get that win and get my name
up on the record boards I have the
record for most stage wins like I'm
joying with it you know I have it I'm
not taking anything away from you yeah
you set a goal you try and achieve it
hopefully you do achieve it I don't want
to be like a non-playing character and
just ride around the pill and that's not
fair on anybody you know everything I do
is always I want a purpose for it within
everything I can control if I do
everything I can do to the best that I
can do it then I'm happy if I know I
just work hard put myself in the best
position to win and I chose made the
decision to retire actually just
because I was happy again like I I lost
so much love for what I was doing I
guess
like forgot why I was doing it and
wouldn't say I'd have ever been bitter
but if you start a career with a love of
something you've done your whole life
you want to finish your career with that
yeah and finally I've got that again and
uh he was like well perfect to stop like
fortunately yeah crashed at the Tour of
France
and that is what it is I was like have a
good look
before a bad look now that's that's life
that's my
yeah yeah yeah it was all sort of lined
up for you last year the crash took you
out by your own words your motivation
was super high and you were very
positive about your prospects and how
you would do so now here we are the next
year the the tour to France course was
just unveiled like how are you feeling
about the season that lies ahead yeah
good we start now and it's to say I've
done it 20 times so I know what to do
and it's quite nice that like know when
I can build towards
July I it was strange for a few years
that you had to fight for your place in
the
team to get even get to July so that
would affect your preparation if you
have to fight fight in quotation but if
you have to prove yourself to go to the
tour within a team so there's eight
Riders from a team go to the tour
Defence and there's 30 riders in a team
so you have to prove yourself sometimes
like for most part of my career it was a
given and I go the tour so I do the best
thing I can to prepare for the Tour of
France for July and there was these few
years like where I had to just try and
getting the team to go the tour yeah and
to do that you need results and that
affects your whole preparation for the
tour cuz you going on to
races you want results in every race you
go to but obviously you can't
specifically train because you're
preparing for a race because you don't
want it's hard to if I train hard before
race like I'm not going to do the best I
can at the race it's a tapering period
you need it's not the train race you
really angling for and this year it's
it's all about the tour so you don't
have to worry yourself with all of these
like early season races and you've got a
whole team that's lined up and organized
around your success this year which is
which is different that's a new thing ex
you put it a lot more eloquently than
yeah but the other thing the other thing
is a little different is that you meet
your de demons a couple amazing people
come into your life to resuscitate what
everyone at that point believes to be
you know game over for you and at the
last minute um you're selected for the
tour in
2021 there's really no pressure on you
because nobody expects anything from you
and you have had this experience of
weathering your mental health journey
and kind of coming out on the other side
of that and entering that race with a a
kind of Newfound perspective before it
wasn't anything if I won cuz I won it
was big if I didn't win mhm all I could
do was lose before whereas now like I
really get the sense both with myself
the people close around me my wider fans
that it's just a bonus yeah do you know
what I mean it's a nice Target to have
to stand
alone staging of the Tor friends but
it's like your identity is not hinged on
how you going to per where for was a
failure if I didn't win mhm there
there's not many sports people that that
happens to it's a it's a failure if they
don't win like you you lose more than
you win yeah if you have a tennis match
with one player versus one player you
have a 50% chance of winning and you
have 200 bite Riders on a 200 kmet
circuit with variables that are
just
infinite you know your chances of
winning significantly reduce my team
boss Alex vinarov he was Olympic
champion in London he had a big crash
the year before he should have retired
and he's like I'm going to win the
Olympics and uh I was favorite for that
race and he won and
uh as a boss he's incredible cuz he says
look we try that's it all we can do is
try we put the work and we do what we
can do and he's 100% right if we do
everything we can do when someone's
better doesn't happen doesn't happen if
we do everything we can do we put
ourselves in the the best chance of of
winning and I think if we do what we do
then the chances of winning are quite
High yeah it's got to be different to
have uh a former Rider especially of his
caliber as the team manager as opposed
to just a manager who who wasn't you
know a rider they have a different lens
on it you feel the difference with a
champion there's Riders I talk in s
speaking you can talk about it a lot
more broader but in Sy speak you have
Riders you have good Riders and they win
and and you have people that win a lot
you know and it's hard to win you know
there's a lot of riders always second
and third which is good like I said out
of pel have nearly 200 Riders getting
consistently second third is good
there's a difference between getting
consistently second and third and
winning to get a win it's crazy
difficult every athlete I know is going
to tell you that having the right gear
is key to Performance if what you're
wearing is poorly crafted it's just
going to put distance between you and
those goals you've set you owe it to
yourself to invest in the best and the
best is on I'm obsessed with the cloud
Ultra great on the trails and I just got
the new nextg Cloud Stratus 3 for the
road I'm loving those but on also has
this incredible line of lightweight high
performance apparel that it's just
beyond anything I've previously dawned
it's like this second to none Second
Skin I love to rock the sweat wicking
Ultra te and the ultra shorts which have
this pocket right at the base of the
spine that perfectly anchors your phone
no jiggle I'm just so proud to partner
with an and I love their vision for the
future where their gear is fossil free
and engineered for circularity so check
out their amazing lineup of super
comfortable sleek and durable pieces for
yourself at
on.com
what is the difference when you look at
good versus great like what is the
differentiator mentally I mean obviously
everybody's training incredibly hard and
they're all going to you know sort of
have watts in the same range and all of
that but Racing's different it's dealing
with pressure was always my answer will
always be my answer it's your ability to
deal with pressure it might be pressure
from someone else it might be pressure
from yourself but there's a pressure to
winning and it's how you deal with that
that is the biggest factor between first
and second so how is your relationship
with pressure changed I never really
felt it
anyway it's more dealing with the
aftermath of that pressure that was
always that that that's change in what I
did uhhuh if it went well obviously I'm
I'm elated like throwing a bouncy ball
in a room you know whereas the other way
I
probably was angry or just over
emotionally the other way you know
lashed out
at myself or other people you know and
uh one sleep at night going over what
happened what happened what happened
what happened things like that whereas
now it's there's not really
that like holding on to it you move on
straight away is is what it is isn't it
how much of that is a result of the work
that you've done on your mental health
with David Spindler and the people that
came into your life at the lowest
moments yeah it's everything to do with
it I think it was just
learning what's important like we didn't
do so much work as such like David was
really good at he's obviously explain it
to me after but he he dropped something
in like a a cue for me to to work it out
myself I didn't know he was doing up
things are going off the rails you're
not winning you've got abstein bar you
got no energy you couldn't make the time
cut in the tour to France you had to
drop out you sink into this depression
you sort of allude to some disordered
eating patterns also and it's a pretty
dark hole that's starting to impact your
your marriage like your whole life feels
like a house of cards that's that's
falling in on itself and this guy David
Spindler comes out to the aisle of man
right and hangs out with you and just
seems like he's just trying to
understand you and get to know you
and it would appear from watching the
documentary that a big part of the way
in towards solving this problem was
helping you reconnect with the joy that
brought you into cycling in the first
place like when you go to the field
where you first learned how to ride and
he starts to understand and see that
that's what you need to recapture in
order to rebuild yeah right we just
realize why I ride my bike it's it's as
simple as that and getting you over the
the hump on this idea a that maybe you
need and could accept some help right
like this idea that mental health is
actually a thing that was a pretty big
hdle how'd he crack you open on that one
I knew something was wrong it was when
like I went and got all the tests the
doctor Helga he's someone I
trusted so much I want to talk about
everything that I felt but the iron is I
didn't feel anything you try and think
back and it's like thinking black into a
just an abyss really do you
know it's quite strange just being
numb and like losing that enthusiasm for
life
and it's different than being sad do you
know I think what I used to not
understand I used to think you just
you're just sad like it's not sad it's a
good way to describe it is you you're
sad but you you're not sad
you're not happy you're just not
anything it's quite easy to see somebody
who maybe they themselves don't know
something's wrong it could be quite easy
to dismiss them as like feeling sorry
for themselves
mhm but they're not yeah yeah I wonder
like in your case how much of it is like
a brain chemistry thing like there's
something broken in the wiring that
needs to get you know figured out and
reconfigured on the one hand then on the
other hand this idea that your identity
is so wrapped up in being a champion
somebody who always wins and when
suddenly that's not happening like
there's an identity crisis like who am I
or you know my purpose is to win races
and I'm like a a machine for victories
and when that's no longer the case like
it's hard for me to dissect that cuz
this obviously observations from the
people around me do you know you don't
feel like that at the time I didn't feel
like that I still kind of don't feel
like that that I had an identity that
went because I couldn't do it I'm just
me I don't know any different how I know
you know it's more observations from the
people knowing me you know like I it
make sense and and a wholeheartedly
agree with what they say unfortunately I
can't analyze it right but what were
some of the things that you began to do
that that started to you know allow you
to claw out of it or start to see the
light people around you that that be all
and end
all like I'm very lucky that I'm very
good people around me you know that were
patient and
just know help me put things in
perspective really beyond your your wife
your family the two people that come to
mind Beyond Spindler are vaszy who comes
in as your coach and you seem to
immediately like resonate with him and
it feels like he understands you and has
a way of communicating with you he's
just straight he's just straight I've
always appreciated someone that's just
straight okay you learn as you're older
you can be straight and still be
diplomatic you know I could say you did
that wrong doesn't help anyone mhm you
might do something wrong instead of just
going you did that wrong that's it like
what' you gain from that there's no
point saying a negative without some
sort of solution you know something you
did you did that wrong you maybe could
have done that there and it would have
gone this way instead of that you know
it's the same thing but it's a positive
in how you say it and uh I've learned to
do that by still being straight and V he
was straight with me it's quite
refreshing I have someone that just
tells you straight you know and did he
also he brought a different kind of
structure to your training like the
physical part of it also he brought our
structure to my training had a structure
before really with that much time that
had away from cycling really you lose
your physical ability as well you know
so that takes a a time to build up I've
been professional by that point over a
decade like and uh the resilience and
that you build up over that time is
compounded from years and years of kilom
after Kil after
kilom and having a big block off it's
like retiring and coming back from
retirement you know it do just happen
you have to work and I think he was able
to do that I still don't like training
structure I don't like how we training
like I'd rather go out and ride you know
but I understand it how is that uh Chang
in involved as you as you're aging up
like in terms of recovery and just being
really precise and intentional about
your workouts is that more important
than it used to be are you still able to
bounce back no the sports changed as
well yeah so you have to
be
more dialed now when I
started he there was Sports Science but
you there wasn't the data there is now
to collect so basically you turn
professional if you won races as an
amateur that that's it mhm now the
majority of the pel they never won a
race as an amateure they just you can
see physically from the data that
they're strong so everybody's strong
not necessarily good bike
riders but strong so like the speed is
just ridiculously high the bikes are
faster so the speeds higher and just
everyone's strong yeah everyone so you
have to level up in terms of your
training but I'm not very good I'm not
like really ride your bike around old
school style yeah really I'm not some
Tempo call a day I'm actually a bit of a
run in cycling you know I
just ride me bike a lot so but there's a
whole generation of cyclists coming up
who to your point incredibly strong
power to weight all that kind of stuff
super dialed they understand the
technology there's all these gadgets and
trackers and there's no end to the
amount of data you can collect and kind
of mind to get better but at some point
that doesn't replace experience or you
know I mean frankly like the balls to
race right like all of that stuff is
more Instinct and experience yeah
Instinct more you still have to work out
you set a plan before and you can know
the more you can go over something the
more you do something the more it
becomes instant you do without thinking
you
know yeah and that's a benefit of age I
guess yeah you've had many scenarios
before I do want to like indulge you
with one thing I want to show you
something can I show you a clip
yeah there goes
cavish cavish is going to die
[Applause]
just something unbelievable and
I was so
proud that's an amazing moment man yeah
it's nice what does it bring up for you
to watch that now I mean you're you're
so emotional it's just this amazing
catharsis where you know everything that
led up to that you know finally you
could kind of Let It
Go
just like my wife Peter said just
holding on it was just finally letting
go of that hold on like it might never
have come might not have won there and
then might never been a Let It Go do you
think about that like had things gone
just a little bit differently like like
you might not have had that opportunity
cuz he didn't you know like we' done
everything we possibly could within our
control to do it you know that's all you
can do and
fortunately made for a successful race
it sounds quite unromantic to like how I
talk about it
it's it's as simple as that really like
just could let go there and then
like and it did happen like that and
that's what but it went like that you
know did you just feel lighter and the
confidence was there like the rest of
the tour after kind of yeah you know
breaking that seal became easier and
more joyful I wouldn't say I felt
lighter cuz I didn't feel pressure
anyway going into that wasn't
like I had everything to gain and of to
lose there you know so it wasn't like I
felt any pressure go cuz it was none
there anyway but I definitely felt the
confidence after that
and I felt the confidence that the boys
had as well and that is a massive Factor
that's always been a
massive driving factor in my
performances
how committed my teammates are you know
you don't necessarily have to be the
strongest but if you committed you're
probably better at everyone else it's
another cliche like
strong team is sure is way stronger than
a team of strong people you know it
feels like your team this year going
into into the tour is very strong you've
got your lead out sorted you got vorov
supporting you you've got vasi you've
got all the elements right so that must
feel good got committed boys I know that
which is which is nice and Lads that
know me you know I work I always think
you get a good sense of how a team's
going to perform
by not how they are on the bike but how
they are at the dinner table so where we
go we stay in hotels and not quite often
you'll have two three four teams in the
same
Hotel of a night and it can change which
teams you're with and that it's too comp
to go how they do the hotels but
uh I always think
normally a team will go to dinner about
the same time finish dinner at the same
time the teams that stay longest after
they finished eating at the dinner table
are usually the most the most successful
teams as a rule of th yeah yeah but the
difference between your sport and a lot
of other sports is you're not training
with these guys day and day out yeah
it's a mad sport like that yeah and even
that that there's only one guy crosses
the line and you've got to be sympatic
with your lead out I'm smaller than most
of the guys as well so I have to trust
whereever they're going and that's built
on a lot more than just being on the
bike and I'm fortunate to have some of
the best most heless
people in the
sport during my career you know I'm very
very fortunate for that it is such a
weird thing though because most of the
training you're probably doing alone
right but that's nothing like the racing
and nothing like the teamwork required
to you know for you to be successful and
your teammates to be successful you come
together for these camps and then you
see each other at races it's mad and can
you imagine it doesn't make sense
actually can you imagine being a lead
out Guy where you know you've got a
train you've got to make yourself
vomiting training by going
hard so that you can go and make
somebody else cross a Finish Line first
okay the team's winning there's only one
Rider has the name on the yeah for me
that's incredibly special
for guys that know their job is to
sacrifice themselves for somebody else
and they'll go out and hurt themselves
at home just so they can hurt more to
support you in the race like it blows my
mind yeah there really isn't any other
sport like that no it's what's so
beautiful about this sport there so many
little things about the sport just make
it just beautiful you know
when you look at the layout for this
year's tour like where's your head at in
terms of it's a different kind of race
this year it's not ending in Paris with
the SHA you're in Italy for part of
it very challenging course yeah for all
Riders but for a sprinter like you don't
choose whether you're a climber or a
sprinter it's a physiological makeup
that
defines if you can go uphill fast or not
doesn't matter how much I trained if I
only trained on Hills I'd still be last
up a hill or one of the last I just
wouldn't be very fast in a Sprint yeah
next year's toour France is very hard
for anybody that can't go uphill decent
like it's always hard you know it's
never easy it's never easy to make a
Time CT to finish it's never easy to put
it into
perspective the last group on the road
on a mountain day which is normally my
group we finish a stage in a faster time
than the winner of what's called letap
theour which is a grand fond massive
amateur event that does one stage of the
toour of friends yeah you get ringer
amateurs out for that yeah you know but
it's a whole different tier yeah it's
not just a just a level above it's in a
complete other level above and then
there's the gap between you know you
being in that final group coming over
the hill versus you know whoever taken
that stage that's a huge time Gap too
yeah it's look sometimes it's like we're
never going easy and talking you're
never doing that but sometimes it's
not as close as it might see say we're
likely to
lose 38 minutes in that one stage on the
on the winner mhm but the time limit is
minutes we're idiots if we only finish
at 38 minutes and not right 44 minutes
yeah yeah yeah because you're not it
doesn't matter yeah it it's really quite
done it's calculated now you can work
out what the win will do and then you
work out how many watts per kilo you
have to do mhm on each climb how much
time you lose on each climb and then you
can work out the overall time you'd lose
so you can you can kind of ride to a
yeah you still have to be able to do
that and it's it's a lot higher than
even your average amate cycl is to be
able to do it's quite calculated it's
just it's it's a math equation you know
for you you know exactly yeah and you've
got it's it's about efficiency because
you're looking at you know the whole
event and where you're going to make
your mark it's not going to be on the
hill exactly it might be taking the show
away from from the commentators you know
they have to make a story about how to
make it exciting but oh look how how
much he's hurting at the back right
you're just like no I'm doing this on
purpose cuz I got you know three days I
got this other stage that I'm thinking
about there's times when we're fighting
to make the liit there is I can't deny
that but it's not that often really yeah
but it's still hard every single
day right the grind of like doing that
day in and day out and having done it
for for 20 years like I can't imagine
and it's a loneliness to be fair yeah
like even though you're not talking
you're not riding if you're in a big
bunch there's so much going on that
you're thinking about that cuz CU any
little thing and you go down yeah when
you're on your own all you're thinking
about is the pain in your legs and
that's actually hard it becomes a mental
thing rather than a physical thing if
that makes sense cuz it's all you it's
all you have to to concentrate on you
have nothing else to you know and uh
it's that day in day out of loneliness
when you think everybody else is for me
that's the always the hardest thing to
overcome if you go on social media and
kind of scroll through you know the the
sort of Fitness influencer ecosystem you
see a lot of people talking about
gadgets or some kind of supplement or
this new recovery modality or that my
sense though of all the kind of super
Elite performers at the highest level of
of their sport do very little or any of
that whatsoever it's like you train hard
you you know eat what you need to eat
you go to bed early you're with your
family you try to see your friends when
you can and that's basically it like is
is that your approach like it's a very
old school approach but my sense is that
like that's how you kind of do it yeah
obviously there's there's big sacrifices
but it's pretty straightforward life
like it's harder for somebody that like
I said it's my job I I get to do what I
love as my job that's all I have to do
as a job is ride my bike but at the same
time in fairness like that's just it's
another year of having to get out there
and the freezing cold and the rain like
ride by yourself and all of that like to
maintain you know kind of the level of
motivation that you need to keep doing
that it's like it's not an easy life
even at your level no but still get to
ride me bik true you know like okay you
would like the choice to not go out if
you didn't want to go out
but quite like going out obviously be
times when I'm not going to be loving it
but I still every day know I'm lucky to
do what I do every single day at the end
of of this year so there's no
pronouncement about whether you're going
to keep going or not no you are you
playing that year by year I don't know
really I'm old now like I'm racing with
you'll be 39 right yeah and I'm racing
with lads who whose dad I race with I
race with their Dads you know there's a
few of them that they're only a year
older than my eldest boy you know it's
it's like Howes they treat you in the
pelaton like what is their relationship
with you as the old guard I don't know
really like I'd only be looking it from
my perspective
but I'm asking like tday paga like he's
one of the Twitter friends two times my
5-year-old is like his biggest fan and
he like signed jerseys and stuff for him
so I'm going asking him for a sign
Jersey and stuff like that uhuh so he's
kind of a bit 25 right he's like 25
years old yeah
he's a good kid like brilliant kid that
L just I don't know they still my
competive if and when you you decide to
you know call it a day for good what
does life look like like do you have a
sense of what you would do where you
would invest your energy I I'll stay in
the sport that's yeah that's for sure
I'm quite happy with my team St at
Kazakhstan so manager maybe in the
future I hope so something like that
we'll see I just love it I love
teaching I love camaraderie being with
my
teammates you know what the only one
thing that I don't like about my
job having to get dressed to go for
breakfast thought you going to say and
doing podcasts like
this hotels like if you go away on a
holiday it's nice to be in a hotel you
don't have to do you wash him make your
bed make your breakfast or dinner and
put when you
spend 78% of your year in a hotel room
honestly like it's so nice to be at home
yeah and not have to get dressed to have
breakfast just go down on my own we and
just make a coffee do you do you still
have to share a room at races yeah it
depends what team you're in really yeah
but I like to share room always have
like climb the walls if I'm on my own I
like to chat joke talk about the day
talk about other stuff like I like
company in the room mhm it means a
single bed instead of a double bed
but yeah I like that company really yeah
the other crazy thing that happened to
you is
this situation where your house was
robbed and these people broke into your
house and from what I read what I
understand like a guy like held you at
night had like a knife to your
neck wasn't anything I wish on anybody I
can't I mean I can't imagine three of
them have been convicted right but
there's still one guy who's yeah at
large they can't track him
down yeah police did a good job really
you
know it wasn't the nicest night I mean I
can't even I can't even rap my head
around that you know what that must have
been
like yeah not nice
like especially it stays with you a long
time after like especially like my my
boy he was three at the time in the room
in bed I just I had had a crash a few
days before uh I had a collapse lung so
I'd been in intensive care a day or so a
few days later my wife had come to pick
me up she drove me home and yeah so I
was in bed a bit bit bad middle of the
night they came in
and they beat me pretty bad but I'm
pretty happy I was there you know like I
I had a friend who was
away
and they tied his
wife and kid up you know and went in his
house the same guys I don't know I don't
I don't think so I don't I don't know
but
uh I count myself lucky yeah that's do
you know I
mean sorry that that happened I can't
fathom it
with all that you've kind of
accomplished and and all the growth that
you've experienced how do you think
about like the young
Mark there a couple of things
but I think I'd say something but then
would that affect you don't know which
way you go with it one don't trust
people like I was just completely
trusting and that leaves yourself quite
open to be you know really burnt you
know
know and like be a bit more don't open
yourself too quickly with people that's
something
but yeah stay humble I think I know when
I was younger could have been a little
bit more
humble at times and I wish I'd been
that's even like talking about before
like where I like smack talk using
somebody's what I perceived as mental
weakness against him yeah
but I didn't know you know it's not it's
not an excuse but at least I also you
you winning everything right so what
does that do to a young mind when when
you trust people that aren't going to
tell you right someone needs to hit you
around the Ed and say stop that right
you know who's given you the honest
feedback you didn't have that when you
needed it early no not really when I was
Pro you know why it's quite common in
professional sports it's like that you
know you're a product at the end of the
day like It's Entertainment you're
you're a product do you know
like as a person you're human but as a
sports person mhm you're a commodity AR
you know yeah we could see this person
you know what I mean and I was so happy
with how they did that like it wasn't my
film I didn't have editing rights and
that on the on the film you know and I
really believe the director Alex The
Producers pitch Netflix I'm so happy
they didn't make it look all shiny and
that like they really showed mhm flaws
and how I can be as a person but
also how vulnerable I can as a person do
you know they they they really
showed showed that I was quite humble
that they did that really you know well
I think that's why it works you know and
I think that's why it's meaningful and I
think that you know I mean first of all
I commend you for opening yourself up to
you know be available for that type of
narrative and conversation you could
have easily said I'll revisit this when
I'm done with cycling you know I you
know what I mean I know it was quite
hard to to film some of it and Alex
the director was super patient like
really really really patient
and I
think he was incredible to be able to
open up to like that and how he stayed
like that and just let me do it cuz it's
hard to talk about as well like trying
to
analyze struggles you have can kind of
put you in a dark place again you know
and you don't
mind if you can share your experiences
and maybe
somebody relates to it it's worth doing
then you
know you do too much and you can it's
talking negatively it can spiral you
down you know well I think it's also an
important piece in in a in a larger
conversation around like Elite Athletics
and and mental health it kind of pulls
the veil on this idea that somebody like
yourself or you know High performer XY
or Z they're immune from these sorts of
conditions and they operate differently
than than normal people when in fact
like the pressures are very real and
you're human just like everyone else and
you giving voice to this gives other
athletes permission to do that because
as you know like everyone is in this
situation where they feel like if
they're vulnerable like that's going to
that's going to really harm their career
like if they let anybody know that
they're actually hurting that's a
in the armor that they don't want their
coach to know they don't want their
competitors to know it might not bode
well for them getting resigned or or
whatever it is unfortunately even if
that's it's not just them thinking that
is detrimental because there's a lot of
people that don't
understand do you know right like
unfortunately it's like that and it it
can be hard for an athlete or a
non-athlete
to deal with their demons or deal with
what's going on or know there's
something wrong and be able to do
something about it that's one that's the
struggle in
itself but when there's other people
making decisions based on a perception
of you that you you can't it's actually
more
detrimental like if you're trying to
fight against something like exactly
what I was
doing it wasn't like I was trying to
fight against what was going on with me
I was having to battle against obstacles
were put in the waym and that's the
problem that that unfortunately you're
facing
there when it's universally
misunderstood like mental health and
it's not to feel s like it's not to feel
sorry for someone never want anyone to
feels sorry for me like why would you
feel sorry it's not uh something that's
good or bad it just
is with an understanding that you don't
need to put obstacles in a way making it
harder than it already is you know to
come out and and and talk about these
things and I think yeah yeah sort of the
the uninformed view of kind of what
happened to you when you were in your
lower moments is listen you know he had
a good career but it's not happening
anymore like the train is moving on you
know like marle figure it out and do
something else with his life the people
who thought that have never done
anything that I've done so how could
they how could they put themselves in
position to think that that that was
always my thought process how can they
say if I can do it or not because they
never done anything that I've done mhm
do you know no I understand and but they
they were the ones stopping me showing
them that makes sense I'm not showing
them doing it it it was like you're try
and go forward and you for every step
you do and you're having to push the
door is being shut like we don't want we
don't want to hear about it and your
your whole thing was like you don't go
from being the best in the world to
suddenly like being not being able
to do it like something's wrong you can
decrease over listen you're old whatever
like blah blah blah like we're done with
you as opposed to well let's try to
understand what Mark is saying here and
the fact that you know good people came
into your life who honored that and you
went on this journey with them came out
the other side and proved like indeed
there was something wrong with you you
addressed it with the physical stuff the
abstein bar but also the mental stuff
and came out you know counterintuitively
having to deal with vulnerability and
mental health and all these things that
you know you probably thought were
weaknesses coming out not just stronger
but a more fully actualized person who's
happier in their life and more grounded
and like can connect with you know
gratitude and all these sorts of things
that you know you put blinders on as an
athlete to perform and realizing that oh
that's a more sustainable source of
strength for me that can power me
through many more years and great
successes is a really powerful
contribution to how people understand
not just mental health but like athletic
performance and I think you've also
sidestepped whatever kind of existential
crisis you might have had in the wake of
retirement thinking well what am I going
to do now I'm used to this like super
you know exciting highlevel rare kind of
life that nobody gets to experience I'm
probably not going to be able to have
those kinds of peak experiences like how
do I make sense of my life whether
you're Michael Phelps or somebody else
who's coming out of a career where their
identity and their whole like kind of
way that they operate is based on that
to suddenly being a civilian you
precipitates more than a few you know
mental health crises in like high
performing athletes yeah but in in all
fairness I've had an idea and got to
like plans and motion on what I'm doing
after I never want to just stop and like
is always you think your dream is to
stop I've worked I've been doing this
since I was a kid going to enjoy my life
now all
like athletes are driven that's why
they're athletes you know it's not just
athletes are driven but many many people
are driven I need something a goal
doesn't matter what it
is I need that I just need one that
allows me time with my kids really you
know cycling takes up a lot of time yeah
the other weird thing about cycling is
that like in other sports especially
really grueling ones when an athlete you
know finally retires they're like I'm
done with that like I don't need to do
that cyclists always continue to ride
like they stay connected to the sport
you know their love affair with the bike
doesn't go away which I think is is
unique and interesting so Dynamic
cycling like you can do it competitively
as a sport you can do it to keep fit on
any level spinning
or Ultra riding or part of
triathlon you can use it as a mode of
Transport you can do it with your
family kids go out and play in the
street and it like like just riding a
bike is just so Dynamic you got no you
go at what speed you want to go at you
know it's social too exactly yeah you
can go out
on your own or with people like you said
like socially you can go for as far you
want as fast you want he flat is so
you're free I always felt free on a bike
that's why I did it I still feel free
now like I think if I'm not doing
Vazzy's efforts like interval sessions
I'm just thinking on my bike if you run
too slow you're walkingh no do you know
what I mean like B like okay you fall
off you can choose the speed you do like
it's brilliant like you
know you'll always ride yeah I'll always
ride I'm not doing a TR one though I'd
like to see you swim though no
mate no like I was at the world Iron Man
Champs in nean I was
like blown away it's impressive it's
incredible but it's so stupid it's so
stupid put your body through that is
like say the gu's in the T of France 20
times I'm just one thing I'm just riding
a bike yeah
well I'm over in a day though you know
yeah do you know what actually more than
the pros is the the people that are
coming in at
midnight like being like yeah that's
special like however many hours 16 hours
whatever like it's easy to push through
physical barriers and mental barriers
like even before I had all my problems
and that it's how far you can push
yourself mentally and
like doing that much time like that
being out there
with just you and your body so
impressive like it's it's like changing
I mean it's one thing to be Sam low or
Christian Blumenfeld or what these guys
you know on the rivet for eight hours um
but the people who are coming in at 12
it's like they're out there so many more
they're suffering longer
right yeah so I don't know maybe you're
gonna not a chance my my team boss Veno
he was world champion this he won the
World Championships like group right
that was a while back I think you should
you should design kits with Paul Smith
yeah he's your guy right yeah he's he
just loves cycling I know he raced when
he was young like and the nicest person
you love me he's still like coming up
with designs for cyclist too yeah if
there's one thing that you're kind of
focused on and working on for this year
like what is the hurdle you're still
trying to overcome to unlock you know
that next level of per performance for
yourself or like what comes up like this
is what I really need to work on this is
my weakness that I'm focused on right
now don't know really like I look at
like last
year and I have a lot more things in
place for for next year than they did
last year but say the to of France
is a lot a lot a lot harder
mhm I have to adapt to that when they
unveil the course how does that impact
you have to tweak and and sort of dial
in your training to customize it not
right now but yeah yeah and any things
that you have to do like you know at now
at 39 that you didn't have to do when
you were 26 oh kind of continue to ride
actually taking a block of time or so
I'm in offseason at the
minute and
uh when I was younger it would be five
six weeks off the bike then you start
again
after I hit
30 it got short and short the amount of
time I could kind of have off the bike
without it taking a long time to get
back yeah your Bas Fitness is always
there you can't let it go for too long
anymore no yeah you feel a lot more
lethargic don't you is there any
training that you do off the bike that's
different like what does the gym workout
look like the other the sort of dry land
other things no I probably do less off
bite work now than I used to all my
stuff is
quite on bike based that's Vazzy's thing
a lot my strength training there's no
gym or anything like that the the
strength Works done on the bike it's all
on the bike and when you're hitting Peak
training how many hours a week are we
looking at 30 35 hours yeah some weeks
you do 15 hours but very high intensity
15 hours you know it varies um the
workload would probably always be
relatively the same you might do just
Less hours with higher intensity I don't
really know I don't I should ride my
bike yeah should just ride my bike you
know I'm trying to make it more
complicated than it is you know it's
actually refreshing honestly I'm
measuring wins really well for me I want
to win you know like at the times when I
have to try and get in the team to go
the tour then all that stuff kind of
matters but it's for other people you
know yeah if I know I could just be left
my own thing own devices to be the best
I could be go with the tour yeah I know
what I need to do to win it's basically
getting fit enough you know exactly what
your power to weight ratio needs to be
you know what the number and you know
how to get there and you want to show up
at the tour healthy fresh and be able to
strike when the opportunity arises and
efficiently ride through the rest of it
so that you can basically be in the best
position you possibly can for those
Sprint opportunities exactly yeah it's
21 days so and you can't control it
there's so many variables right like you
know everything you do on the first and
second day even though you will have it
a knock on effect on the 18th and 19th
days you know for instance if it was a
really flat first 10 days you'd probably
go with a little bit more weight you'd
lose a weight in the first 10 days
before you got in the mountains but
you'd have a a more powerful Sprint
whereas it was Hil at the beginning you
need to be able to get to the Sprints as
well so
you'd change your body shape and that by
by by different training so depending on
the course yeah yeah I'm going too
complicated now even I'm getting bored
talking about it
so I'm going to let you go in a few
minutes man don't worry about it two
more things I want to ask you one is uh
was anything left out of the documentary
that you wish had been in there or is
there any aspect of who you are that you
think it's misconstrued in the press or
that people kind of don't understand
about the real
Mark I don't know really
don't I I don't know if it really
matters if someone who doesn't know
you who who's never met you will never
met
you has
a opinion on
your personality mhm
like they could be right but most
probably they're wrong about your
personality you know for good or bad I
don't know you know unless you know
someone someone I know or meet if I make
them happy that's good if I upset them
then I that's a problem with me I I
should sort that out you know if you're
affecting somebody's life or how they
are now their day then that's something
you've got to MH address my
kids they pretend to be their
favorite sports person or pop star like
that's when you
understand your job as a cyclist really
you know someone want it can be a kid or
it can be a even an adult like you know
when you go out don't say you haven't
done it you you imagine that person
you're seeing on TV you've done it for
sure you've done it you might have been
a kid when you you imagine you're
someone that's our job you know to be
that person when you meet those people
yeah oh no when you don't meet them so
it's not your personality it's what you
do but when you meet them then it's
important to be the person you want them
to to believe you are if you're a good
person you bring them Joy if you're not
you affect them
negatively that's so interesting though
because you're thinking about this not
just in terms of how you perform as an
athlete but how you're perceived as a
public person and the
responsibility yeah I'm not talking
about how I'm perceived I'm talking
about being you want you want to equit
yourself the way that yeah yeah I
understand that I you should do it for
especially in the world now with with
social media and the light that you can
manipulate who you are sure don't be
perceived to be a good person be a good
person do you know like it's like you
shouldn't even have to say that you know
what I
mean I have heard things
about I met
him myself met him 15 years ago he was a
dick
mhm I was a dick I was I'm you don't I'm
not a dick now I realize I'm a dick
right based on a 10 second encounter
that you had where that person was
probably really excited to meet you and
you were in a bad mood or whatever and
now his whole view of who you are was B
is based on that there's
someone over at another team bus with
another Rider you signed 100 autographs
for those 100 people mhm when you're
down to the last three who've been
waiting there for 2 hours that person
has finished getting that one from there
and comes and waits there but you're
done you have to go the bus is going
it's not the bus has to go and you leave
you're not being a dick right do you see
what I mean no I understand yeah you
can't fulfill that expectation all the
you can't and it but there was times in
the past when I could have signed 50
autographs and I didn't I wish I knew
before I kids how much that means to
sign autographs do you know kids is the
reason I know
but probably I was a dick for not
realizing that before do you know yeah
do you know what I mean yeah I
understand but it's
also you know viewing that charitably
like you know you're probably younger
and my job is to race a bike like I I'll
sign as many as I can but I have other
things to do too like I can't just be
available I could make people perceive
me as being nice but it wasn't that I
was just a dick yeah okay you know I
have to be truthful I didn't really care
right I get it you know but I don't see
a dick sitting across from me right now
I see I see like a pretty nice grounded
dude and I guess like that leads to the
final kind of question I want to ask you
which is you know this podcast thing
that I do if there is like one
overarching theme it's really about
growth and evolution and change like how
can we become better people how can we
be more fulfilled you know live more
purposeful meaningful lives you know be
a little bit more compassionate and self
Ed and when I look at kind of the
changes that you've gone through and
your own personal transformation and
growth as not just an athlete but as a
human being and this kind of mental
health Journey that you went on like I
see somebody who's who's earned their
transformation like you've grown up in a
lot of ways right and I just want to
leave the audience with some thoughts
about that process if somebody's
thinking about like how can I kind of
level up who I am as a person or how can
I welcome a little bit more discomforted
in my life to to grow and challenge
myself like as somebody who's on the
other side of one chapter of that like
what do you tell that person or what can
you impart from what you've learned in
the experiences that you've had
right for me of course you can have
negatives but find a solution to any
negative or look for a solution to turn
it into a positive like negativity drags
you down and that's not to say just
don't be negative that's like saying
before don't be depressed that's not you
know it's if you can
find solutions to whatever negative
thing is going on it doesn't have to be
negative thoughts it don't have to just
just anything that there should never be
a problem you should look at the
solution of the problem just I can't do
it because it's a problem or I can't
it's you might not be able to do it but
it turns into a positive rather than a
negative and it's a massive weight
lifted like the glass is always half
full it's not half empty if you can look
at life like
that you can do what you want to do you
know just take it from experience cuz I
never thought like that before and it's
been an absolute Game Changer to me not
harboring negativity finding a positive
way to look at
things that's a great way to go into
this season man I'm happy for you dude
you know it's cool it's it's really cool
to you know you're so clearly in in this
really good place in your life like
emotionally and it's one thing to be in
that place and it's another thing to
recognize it like you really recognize
like this cool life that you have the
opportunities that you have thanks man
I'm lucky like how I have an incredible
wife that's took by me for everything
and I I realize why have got an
incredible beautiful family I get to do
what I love as a job there there's
nothing
to yeah things are perfect you know
that's a good way to end it man things
are perfect right thanks man that was
great you're you're an inspiration uh
you know I've been a fan for a long time
but now you know knowing you a little
bit and getting to know you through the
documentary like I I really appreciate
you know the journey that you are on and
what you're trying to do man so I'm
really excited for the season to come
for you thanks rich thank you cheers
thanks for doing
[Music]
this that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at Rich roll.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch my
books Finding Ultra voicing change in
the plant power way as well as the plant
power meal planner at meals. ral.com if
you'd like to support the podcast the
easiest and most impactful thing you can
do is to subscribe to the show on Apple
podcasts on Spotify and on YouTube and
leave a review and or comment supporting
the sponsors who support the show is
also important and appreciated and
sharing the show or your favorite
episode with friends or on social media
is of course awesome and very helpful
and finally for podcast updates special
offers on books the meal planner and
other subjects please subscribe to our
newsletter which you can find on the
footer of any page at Rich roll.com
Today's show was produced and engineered
by Jason Cameo with additional audio
engineering by Kale Curtis the video
edition of the podcast was was created
by Blake Curtis with assistance by our
creative director Dan Drake portraits by
Davey Greenberg graphic and social media
assets courtesy of Daniel CIS thank you
Georgia Wy for copywriting and website
management and of course our theme music
was created by Tyler Patt traper Patt
and Harry mathys appreciate the love
love the support see you back here soon
peace plant
namaste
[Music]
every